All right. Neil Schloss,
thank you so much
for joining on 20 Minute Leaders.
Good to be here. Thank you.
So wonderful, so gracious of you
to give me your time, Neil.
You have one
of the most impressive
careers that I’ve come across --
36 years at Ford.
You’ve seen so much
that I don’t know how we can try
to summarize this in 20 minutes.
But I’m going to try.
And I'd love to spend this time
learning from you what it means
to be at an amazing company
like Ford over these years,
seeing these incredible
technological transformations
as you go through,
seeing the great recession of 2008
as you’re taking part
as an active CFO of the
Ford Mobility subsidiary,
but also helping the Ford company
secure some huge liquidity
to help go through this crisis.
Neil, let’s start off with you.
How did you even get to Ford?
And how did you end
spending 36 years there?
Yeah, there’s a luck piece.
There’s a faith piece
that puts you in the right place
at the right time.
But born and raised in San Diego.
I went to San Diego State.
Was intending to be
a chemistry major.
And after I couldn’t get through
Calculus with any meaningful grades,
I decided it’s probably
not the best place to be
as far as the business.
So, I took an econ course.
I said this was pretty cool stuff.
And so, I picked up
the finance skillset
in undergrad.
And coming out of school in 1982,
which was the end of the --
sort of the --
not depression,
but clearly an economic recession
that was going on,
Ford was the only one hiring.
And so, I got the one offer
coming out of school.
They were hiring in their aerospace
division, which was in Palo Alto.
Wow.
And so, I actually started
with Ford in Palo Alto.
So, being born and raised
in San Diego, moving north,
spent five years
or so in the bay area,
then to Southern California
before the aerospace.
And then, we sold the business
and had a chance to stay
with Loral who was
the acquirer or move to Detroit.
And who knew what
Detroit would be like.
So, moving from 70 degrees
and sunny every day to --
when I moved in January,
- it’s to white snow on the ground.
- Wow.
It was a bit of a culture shock.
And then spent 30 years here
in Detroit with them,
or 28 years with them.
I’ve been here now
30 years in a variety
of different finance roles.
Joined the treasury organization
about a year and a half
into my tenure here.
Fell in love with the markets.
Fell in love with the ability
to get sort of real-time
performance reviews.
So, every day,
you are in the market trading.
You were getting --
at the end of the day,
you knew if you did
a good job or not.
Wow.
And I think the external focus
was also an important aspect
that most big companies --
your jobs are focused internally.
And the treasury roles
tended to be with investors,
with banks, with advisors.
So, it’s much more an external
focus to the lot of treasury,
different roles.
And then, got my dream job
in March of ’07 when I became
treasurer for the company.
Had a team of about
300 folks globally.
Wow! Of Ford?
Hmm?
- Of Ford, right?
- Of Ford, yeah.
Unbelievable.
In the US center,
and then three different
international centers in China,
in Brazil, then in Europe.
Hold on. So, you’re --
the treasurer of the company
in 2007, which is a fabulous time
to become the treasurer of a huge,
huge company that’s about to be
hit like every other company,
and I believe without bailout,
you helped the company go through
this crisis, raising $23 billion
in liquidity.
Talk to me about this.
Paint me a picture.
I was just a little kid.
I was actually in the stock market
class of December  of ’08
when my teacher --
he was my Math teacher as well,
[Joe Liss]. He walks in, and says,
“Kids, just so you know,
you’re going to be
telling about this class,
about today, to your grandkids
when you’re older because this is
one of the most unique moments
in history that you get to be
in the stock market class
during this crisis.
I had the privilege
of playing with Excel,
with makeshift investments.
You had to be
the treasurer of Ford.
Talk to me about this crisis.
I think it goes back really
when I was in the
system treasure back in ’06.
It was when we did
the financing deck
and the large home improvement loan
that everybody talks about,
the $23 billion.
It was done in December 2006.
Because it was actually
before the financial crisis,
before the auto crisis,
we were having our own issues
that were unique to the company
as well as a starting
of a slowdown in the industry.
We raised $23 billion.
And I remember
several meetings that --
it’s, “How much can we get?
How much can you take?”
And one thing you’ll learn
in a cyclical industry
as a treasurer is you take money
when people want to give it to you,
not when you need it.
- I’ve heard this so many times.
- And that’s true today
by the way as well.
If I think about start-ups
and think about the venture world
in a crisis like this,
the people who took money
early are in much better position
than those that didn’t.
And you take money when people
want to give it to you,
and not when you need it.
- So, we needed there --
- And when you need it,
you never get it.
So, along this line --
because it seems a little bit
contradicting sometimes
when you think of the lean
startup bootstrapping.
Don’t give away too much equity.
Hold onto to what you can and try
to power through,
you're actually --
You and a lot of other really,
really incredible
people are saying,
“No, no. No.
This is a cyclical market.
You’re going to have a rainy day.
Make sure you have enough capital
to power through whatever happens,”
like COVID,
like the great recession.
Yeah. And I think you have to look
at it from the standpoint of --
maybe we can get into this later.
But I think you have look at it
from the standpoint of who your
customers and your clients are.
It’s not your business
that's necessarily --
that's -- you know,
you're susceptible
to your own risks.
But if your clients are impacted
by economic recession,
in which case, your business --
your revenue goes away,
it’s more than just
your own business, because it's
to your customer risks.
But anyway, back to ’07.
The auto industry started
to have problems in ’07.
The banking industry started
with Bear Stearns in March of ’08.
AIG and Lehman
in September of ’08.
The auto task force was set up,
the congressional hearings.
And we didn’t know
where things were going to end.
So, we went through a huge amount
of work in a period of ’06 to ’09,
basically buttoned down as much as
we could to raise
as much funding as we could.
We did equity swaps.
We took that out
at pennies on a dollar,
which I hope to never do again.
We drew on our credit revolver.
- Wow.
- And when it came down to --
I guess May of ’09
when Chrysler went under,
and then, soon thereafter GM,
the key for us was making sure
we kept the liquidity we needed,
but also that the supply base
had its liquidity because
if the supply base were to go,
you couldn’t sustain yourself.
And so, I think it was better
to be lucky than good.
In some cases, we raised
enough money early enough.
We were creative
on how we did things.
We had a management team
that was focused on product line
and prioritizing what vehicles
we needed to produce by when.
And I think the
leadership team all --
We met every single day --
- Wow.
- Held hands and --
―not literally, but figuratively―
held hands and fought through it
and did what we could do to keep
us from having to go under.
So, I mean how do you go about
thousands of employees are unsure
of what’s happening?
You’re saying you meet every day
as a leadership team,
which means that every day
there’s new insights,
there’s new decisions
and new adaptations.
How do you actually --
and you’re in charge
of a division of 300 people.
Yup.
How do you even communicate
this crisis and optimism,
realistic pessimism?
Yeah. Today, actually, would be
a lot easier because you can just
set up a Zoom
and you can talk to 300 people.
Get everybody on and you can give
everybody sort of daily updates
or you could do
five-minute videos to send out.
I think the technology today
would have made it easier.
Unfortunately, we also see
companies who are
it’s too easy. And you know,
- we've seen
- Yeah.
some pretty
nasty lay-offs recently, yeah.
When you go through crisis,
it’s better to over-communicate
than under-communicate.
Yes.
I think the other piece --
and I think this is something
I probably didn’t
know enough early on.
But I think that the ability
to show calm, show confidence --
you obviously have to empathize
with those folks that are
going to lose their jobs.
You have to show positive emotion,
that you know what you’re doing,
you’re confident in what
you’re doing because you need --
you’re not doing the work.
So, as a leader you’re not
physically doing the work.
And so, you need your team
to be energized, to believe
in the cause and to know that
their leaders are taking care
of them and providing
the oversight and guidance
and strategic direction.
But they have to physically feel
that they want to do the work
and they want to be successful
because the heart and minds will
follow  if you have good leaders.
And I think we had
a great leadership
team headed by Arnold Riley
and the support of the board
for what we were trying to do,
which was to survive.
- As a leader, did you --?
- We didn't know what tomorrow --
You know, we took every --
I mean I just remember some
of the conversations I had at home
when I came home --
you come home late,
you get in early,
and just talking to my wife
not knowing exactly what tomorrow
was going to bring,
and whether or not
we would survive.
That’s just fascinating.
And Neil, did you ever have
as a leader, some moments
where you had to portray
optimism even though
deep inside, you’re like,
“Oh, wow! I’m not actually sure --
I’m not actually sure about this”?
I’m not a sugar coater.
So, from the standpoint
of giving somebody a bunch of BS
just to keep them happy
is not my character.
It’s not my leadership style.
I’m transparent
and that’s going to be --
I’m very transparent
in how I feel, in how I act.
And I think from my perspective,
you can do it with the reason
you’re doing stuff,
the mode, in which
you’re doing stuff, the emotion.
You have to stay balanced
because you lose it
if you’re over --
if you’re cheerleader every day
of the week
and you’re cheerleading,
your team won’t believe it.
Right.
If you blow up all the time and --
you know, they won’t believe it.
And so, you have to show balance
in what you’re doing.
And I -- when I got angry
and when I would explode,
they took me seriously
because it did not
happen very often.
And it was --
even though you try not to,
you try to avoid
making it personal, that’s hard.
But I do think
you have to be balanced.
You have to be transparent
in everything you do
because shadow of a leader
is a real concept.
People will follow
and behave the way you behave.
- Definitely.
- If you're a jerk
they’ll be a jerk
because you got ahead.
So, by definition,
it pays to be a jerk, right?
And so, from that perspective
you got to really be aware
that people are watching
everything you do --
Right.
-- all the time, what you say,
how you do it. Non-verbal
is just as important as verbal,
maybe more so
because people tend to believe
your non-verbal more than
they believe your verbal.
Right.
But those, I think --
that sort of --
you got to get through it,
but they got to believe you.
- I'm looking back...
- Then, they’re going to follow.
I’m looking back at my time
as a team leader in the army,
And I’m thinking --
one of the big lessons
that I’ve learned was that
I wanted to be the best
all the time. And so, I would --
I always communicated that
whatever we’re doing always
critically important
and it’s important
that we meet every milestone.
And looking back,
I can see exactly
what you’re saying
that at some point,
these words of this is critical,
this is important,
they’re starting to lose value
because not everything
can be important.
And I think that --
And now I’ve realized
that as a leader,
it was my responsibility
also to know how to delegate
the importance of
the different tasks
so that when there is something
that’s really urgent,
they’ll take it seriously
because all of a sudden,
a year into it,
there was something
that was really urgent and I said,
and they’re like,
“Yeah, but last week
was urgent, too, and two weeks ago
was also urgent."
So, as a leader,
you have to balance. I love that.
But, Neil, one of  --
You also have to find that time
where you can go
away from everybody.
Mm-hmm.
and explode.
[laughter]
Right?
Or express feelings
and emotions --
and my wife took a burden
of a couple of them.
And when you come home,
the little teeny things
that you’ve been built up
and built up and built up,
you explode.
But for me, it was biking.
For me, it was Shabbat,
I mean shutting down
for 25 hours was
critical to being able to
to stay focused.
Yeah, I know. I think I read
somewhere that you mentioned
that your co-workers,
when it hit three 3PM on a Friday,
they would look at the clock,
and say, “Neil, I think it’s
time for Shabbat.
Please go home,”
- which is a little bit --
- I had a boss -- I had a boss
that did that once
in a meeting, and said,
“Don’t you need to leave?”
It was great.
Incredible. Incredible.
Now I think I --
you know, just unders --
like empathizing
with your co-workers
and understanding
the different circumstances.
That’s wonderful.
And I’m imagining there weren’t
too many observant Jews in Ford,
especially, in executive
positions back then.
So, I think
that’s really remarkable.
Nope, there wasn’t but they
were over the top on
supporting what I was doing.
Amazing. Neil, you mentioned also
that you’re not a big car guy.
Or you didn’t grow up
a huge car guy,
yet you spent 36 years in Ford,
in a car company, obviously.
So, are you a car guy now
or are you still more of a --
economics guy
that helped lead a huge company?
It’s funny because I wasn’t
a car guy and I never claimed
to be because --
I like to drive cars
but do I care how they operate;
do I care how they work?
I really don’t, right?
And that was an odd ball at Ford
because you had people
who collected cars, who --
I had a boss at one point
who had an old Ford pick-up truck,
like in the 1930-some
odd pick-up truck.
And he and his brother
would build it,
and then take it apart,
and then build it,
and take it apart.
And it was just like
I could never understand.
That to me was just like, “Why?”
But it’s funny now because what
I’m doing now post-Ford
is all about automotive 2.0.
It’s all about how transportation
is evolving, how mobility
is evolving. And so, I really --
I’m not a car guy,
but I am now
becoming a transportation,
an efficient transportation
person who really --
I can dig. I can really dig into
now the technology,
how things are working.
Help people move
from spot A to point B --
- Right.
- And...
-- on that. And so, where I wasn’t
a technical car guy before,
I’m becoming much more
of a transportation
auto person today.
- Where is this going?
- And I’m spending most of my time
doing that.
Where is transportation going?
What are like the big things
that you’re passionate about
and you’re saying like,
“Wow. This is crazy.
Well, I think it was all headed
toward sort of micro-mobility,
shared mobility, unique use
cases, and how people travel
from point A to point B,
whether it's everything from
using your legs to spaceships.
Right? That mode of transportation
is now just not when -- you know,
I grew up and I spent 36 years
working on manufacturing, assembly
or designing, manufacturing,
selling, financing cars, was
the transportation business model.
That was automotive 1.0.
And you lost touch
with the customer
post either the dealer
relationship and/or the warranty --
Right.
-- and you didn’t really get the
customer until they needed
a transportation.
So, it was very narrow.
That whole thing has been expanded
to what services can I provide?
How do I add different
modes of transportation,
the whole public service
transportation is a broken model.
Cities are a broken model.
There are so many things
from an efficiency perspective
that we can create
that the startup world is
just like hitting home runs on --
from the standpoint of improving
the way this was all going.
And there are so many different
technologies that are being
developed that -- you know,
some will work, and some won’t.
And some won’t work because
they have a great technology,
but they haven’t figured out
the business model for which
that technology could be utilized.
So, where is it going?
Who the heck knows?
- Who knows?
- It’s going. It’s going.
And I think we have to
take it step by step.
Obviously, there's
electronic vehicles, new battery.
There's autonomous vehicles will
come at some point.
Right now, there’s a lot
of technology to make that happen
in an efficient way,
but there’s a lot of work
to be done yet
on all the used cases
from the standpoint
of who’s making those decisions
on what you hit priority-wise.
You know, if you can --
if you hit an old lady, or be
hitting a fire hydrant, right?
Those are decisions
that people have to make.
It’s not a computer that’s going
to make those decisions.
- And those are tough decisions.
- [unclear] what’s fascinating,
I took an ethics and AI class
at Stanford and one of
the fascinating things
that came up was that,
“Yes, the humans need to decide
whether you hit
the fire hydrant or the person.
But at the end also,
there’s the famous
trolley problem of
do you push a button
to switch the train tracks
to hit an older person,
rather than the baby on the tracks.
And it turns out that also
different countries have
different skills of
what they’re willing to do.
I believe MIT did a huge study
on this and I think
it’s a fascinating world
we’re going to.
And  you mentioned start-ups.
So, now you’re also very involved
with J-Ventures as an LP and --
Yup.
helping start-ups.
So, how do you transition now
from 36 years at Ford
to helping start-ups
and looking towards this future?
I think it's pretty crazy.
Yeah. I mean the transition for me
happened in my last two years
at Ford when I was really helping.
I left the treasury role,
was the CFO of Ford Mobility
and Ford Mobility,
when I came on board,
had five employees
and we were just getting started.
So, it was like a start-up
inside of Ford --
Yeah.
-- which has its own issues.
And so, I was employee number 5,
I think, or thereabouts.
And we then would often --
we bought four
different companies.
We started our own
- Wow.
- businesses.
And so, we were a start-up
inside and sort of
operating that way.
And so, transitioning
from the treasury role
in the financing business
into the mobility business
became sort of a nice transition
point to retirement from Ford,
and starting to work heavily
into the start-up world,
focusing obviously
on the automotive
business on mobility.
And got lucky
and got connected
to a couple of start-ups
where I joined their boards.
I’m doing something
with a bank to capitalize
on my treasury skills as well.
And then, J-Ventures,
I got introduced to Oded
sort of the end of last,
last year through an existing LP.
And that’s been six, seven
months now.  It’s been great.
I’ve met a lot of folks.
The networking,
the quality of the team,
both in J-Ventures but also
the LPs are just phenomenal.
A hundred percent.
And the ability to learn
from people in this business
and to make new friends,
and to make new acquaintances,
and open more doors,
it’s been great.
I love it. I love it.
Neil, I can’t believe
20 minutes are almost up.
But I have to ask
the most important question --
three words that best describe you.
Well, I’ve used transparent already
once or twice in this discussion.
So, I’ll probably use that one
again from a standpoint of --
I'm a transp --
you know, it’s all --
for me, it’s all about leadership.
And so, it’s about
being transparent.
It’s about being honest.
And I would say, mentor
would be the third one.
And again, it gets
to -- my leadership philosophy
is helping others get to where
they need to go,
which is mentorship piece of it.
Being transparent,
so there’s no doubt
about where you are.
There’s no question about
what your objectives are.
And then, honesty is sort of a --
you can’t do any of that stuff
if you’re not honest.
Transparent, honest and mentor.
I love it. Neil,
thank you so much.
Toda raba. This was wonderful.
I learned so, so much.
And I’ll see you around J-Ventures.
Hopefully, in person.
I would definitely love so.
Thank you.
All right. Take care, man.